[Music]
Wow RuPaul's Drag Race is back for
Season nine andrew is given eto rundown
of the new girls
Nina Bo Nina Brown oh my goodness that
name if you've heard her full name you
would be really shocked take a bite of
this peach shake cool a shake who Leigh
is a Chicago girl we've had a lot of
successful Chicago girls Chicago is a
great city for drag queens valentina so
gorgeous
reminiscent of the Hollywood stars
Sascha velour stop Sascha velour is one
of our art school intellectual Queens
who does a sort of avant-garde twist on
drag very very smart girl Kimora black
come over black the body
why gotta be black bow down [ __ ]
Alexis Michelle she's auditioned I
believe every single season and she
finally got all it's taking every bit of
me not to piss my panties pheromone
she's a sweet girl from Vegas she's one
of the our news peppermint another New
York girl she knows her way around a
stage and that's what our show is billed
for she's been busy for a long time your
edges are officially snatched Asha Asha
is a Brooklyn girl and she's the first
to let you know if she is from the BK
and she makes no qualms about it James
Mansfield James Mansfield that name
alone I ex me a little extra to say
James Mansfield you know because your
mouth has to make a full stop before
James Mansfield yes mama
Charlie hides Charlie hides is another
so creative I've been a fan of Charlie
hides
viral videos for years and years Trinity
Taylor treinta to Taylor she is another
body Queen and she'll be the first to
tell you that um probably 95% of her
body parts are made in a laboratory I
love plastic
and I went from a pancake to a
Kardashian oh wow and Eureka O'Hara
Yuriko hair ito is from the tri-state
area of Johnson Tennessee the south is
mecca for drag queens and she represents
the south in a big way and I do mean big
way so why were these the right ladies
for season 9 well let Roo explain our
show is put together as an ensemble so
each girl represents certain genre like
a comedy queen or a you know a
head-shaking girl you know all of that
we're looking for authenticity a lot of
the Queens will audition send it an
audition reel where they do the exact
same audition as the girl before 9 out
of 10 of the Queens will say I will cut
a [ __ ] if I get on your show RuPaul I
will cut a [ __ ] they don't realize
everyone has actually said that it's
important for not just our drag queens
but for everybody listening find your
authentic self know thyself and deliver
that at all times that is when the party
begins
[Music]
you